heute beginnt die große
un-klimakonferenz in glasgow gegen 12
uhr heute mittag ist die eröffnung auch
mit angela merkel und olaf scholz wir
werden natürlich live dabei sein und
weil es immer schwieriger wird die
erderwärmung einzugrenzen ist eine
renaissance der fast co2 freien
atomkraft in die diskussion gekommen wir
sehen hier die bilder ja tschernobyl
oder auch fukushima zwei katastrophen
hatten aus der kernkraft das schwarze
schaf quasi der energiebranche gemacht
aber die energiepreis explosionen lässt
viele nun umdenken macht die kernenergie
sogar plötzlich wieder populär jeder
zweite deutsche will dass atomkraftwerke
weiterlaufen und nicht wie eigentlich
beschlossen ende 2022 abgeschaltet
werden denn kernkraftwerke produzieren
unter anderem nahezu kein co2 und
liefern stabil die gleiche menge an
energie
können wir uns also einen ausstieg aus
der kernenergie in deutschland überhaupt
leisten war eine der folgenreichsten
entscheidungen in angela merkels
amtszeit vielleicht sogar ein fehler
diskutieren wir darüber hier jetzt bei
bild live und zwar mit sachsen anhalts
mit bildpolitik chef jan schäfer und
sachsen anhalts
umweltminister sven
schultze da sind sie hallo ich bin auch
nicht der umweltminister das bild der
wirtschafts mehrere wird
noch wichtiger weil alles hängt zusammen
deshalb die frage wie lange können wir
uns das noch leisten
die situation hat sich erst noch mal ein
bisschen verschärft auch in deutschland
wenn wir sehen dass die neue koalition
jetzt schon planen 2030 aus der
atomstrom auszusteigen
2022 das ist ein konsens eigentlich
gewesen richtig wollten wir aus der
atomstrom oder atomkraftwerke schließen
dicht machen die letzten sechs stück die
wir noch haben so und dann muss man
erklären wo dann die energie herkommen
solle jeder weiß dass wir zukünftig weit
mehr strom brauchen als wir jetzt im
moment zur verfügung haben jeder weiß
dass von der energiesicherheit brauchen
das heißt ständig zur verfügung stehende
energie und die hass zweiten dann wenn
der wind nicht weht oder wenn die sonne
nicht scheint die halb aus regenerativen
energien nicht und das wichtigste auch
noch zum schluss jahren zwischen
angesprochen wir haben auch klimaziele
einzuhalten die franzosen wir haben
klimaziele deshalb einer oder über einen
weg einhalten wollen die haben halt
kernenergie und das muss man halt
letzten endes auch berücksichtigen diese
thematik sollte man zumindest noch mal
an diskutieren es ist so eine rolle
rückwärts jahre hat auch gar nicht so
einfach wie vielleicht gedacht ich meine
ganzen energiekonzerne haben sich ja
auch schon darauf eingestellt dass 2022
nun mal auch schluss sein wird wie
können sie sich wie kann man sich das
vorstellen wie würde das überhaupt gehen
dass man da sagt man macht das doch
nicht ja sie haben ja recht aber auch
alle an die bevölkerung die wirtschaft
die energieintensive wirtschaft hat sich
auch darauf eingestellt dass wir erst
2038 aus der kohleverstromung aussteigen
jetzt kriegen wir hier eine ansage aus
berlin von frau werbung die ja
bekanntermaßen aus dem völkerrecht kommt
ich als ingenieur sehe das ein bisschen
anders hier sagen können auch schon 2030
aussteigen und keiner sagt uns wo soll
denn die energie herkunft und sie haben
vollkommen recht jahren einen ausstieg
aus der kernenergie besprochen nach
aktuellem stand wird das auch so sein
als ende 2022 die letzten atomkraftwerke
hier letzten endes abgeschalten werden
aber wenn wir jetzt eine neue debatte
kriegen und nicht wissen wo denn der
strom herkommen soll und vw aber auch
noch sagt gas als brückentechnologie kam
für sie nicht in frage dann stehen wir
vor einer situation dass wir in
deutschland
tausende und abertausende arbeitsplätze
verlieren können in der
energieintensiven wirtschaft wir stehen
davor dass die menschen millionen von
menschen jetzt demnächst höhere
strompreise zu zahlen haben von den
gaspreisen mal ganz abgesehen nord
stream 2 ist beispielsweise bei einer
neuen regierung scheinbar auch nicht so
gewünscht also dann muss man uns auch
mal erklären hier um mir als
wirtschaftsminister in einem sehr
energie energie ganzen land wie das denn
alles funktionieren soll sollte denken
sie nur daran die laufzeit zu verlängern
oder denken sie auch daran neue mini
atomkraftwerke zu bauen der in vielen
ländern in planung sind großbritannien
beispielsweise dort will rolls royce in
den bau von kleinen kernkraftwerken
einsteigen bill gates in den usa auf
frankreich will das machen großes thema
gerade diese kraftwerke in glasgow beim
un-klimagipfel auch denken sie auch an
so etwas also ich sage ganz ehrlich wenn
überhaupt dann können wir im moment nur
darüber nachdenken über eine
laufzeitverlängerung wenn das in
irgendeiner form wirklich ist das hängt
auch damit zusammen dass neue
atomkraftwerke sich im moment nicht
rechnen wirtschaftlich relativ teuer
sind wir sind auch in deutschland mit
elf prozent des stroms dem wir aktuell
noch aus den atomkraftwerken beziehen
relativ weit unten in der in der summe
das ist in frankreich ganz anders
deswegen glaube ich ist sollte zumindest
der debatte sein gibt es eine
möglichkeit der laufzeitverlängerung
unter der voraussetzung dass wir das
wirklich brauchen und ich glaube wir
könnten es dann brauchen wenn die neue
regierung sich bei den anderen bereichen
nicht gas als brückentechnologie nämlich
früherer ausstieg aus der
kohleverstromung und dass wir es nicht
schaffen die regenerativen energien in
der kurzen zeit die uns dann zur
verfügung steht auszubauen dann muss die
neue regierung auch eine antwort geben
wo der strom herkommen soll und dann
habe ich angeregt auch hier in der bild
zeitung mit ihnen gemeinsam natürlich
auch das vorangetrieben dass wir hier
drüber nachdenken sollten über eine
verlängerung der laufzeiten der aktuell
6 noch in deutschland befindlichen
atomkraftwerke mehr habe ich nicht
angelegt ja schutz wir haben ja gerade
auch noch eine sehr interessante grafik
eben eingeblendet ich wiederhole noch
mal ganz kurz so wird der deutsche strom
produziert kernenergie liegt bei 12,1
prozent erdgas 12,8 kohle 20,8
erneuerbare energien
51,9 und sonstige 2,4 ich wollte noch
mal mit ihnen auf dieses spannende die
spannende zahl von der erneuerbaren
energie eingehen
51,9 warum kann man da nicht einfach
sagen wir liegen da noch was drauf was
macht das so schwierig die schwierigkeit
ist nicht die gesamtsumme sondern die
verfügbarkeit ich kann da ich kann das
auch verdoppeln wenn ich irgendwie
hinkriege aber wenn kein wind weht dann
habe ich nichts zweimal nun ist auch nur
genau wie ein wir haben unzählige
großunternehmen in deutschland die
abhängig davon sind das sich ständig
strom zur verfügung kann ich habe in
meinem bundesland habe ich ein
unternehmen das ist weltweit führend für
den bereich das dass wir alle brauchen
wenn wir ein dieselfahrzeug fahren die
haben die produktion deshalb schon
gedrosselt weil der gaspreis im moment
sehr hoch ist und so könnte man das
durch stecklinge ja noch andere dinge
auch es geht um die energie
verfügbarkeit und es geht auch darum
dass die menschen mitgenommen werden
müssen ich habe in meinem bundesland
unzählige windanlagen weit mehr auf die
bevölkerung gerechnet als beispielsweise
der grüne ministerpräsident in baden
württemberg das heißt dieser windenergie
die photovoltaik muss auch dann bei den
menschen akzeptiert werden wir brauchen
leitungen dass die von den
bürgerinitiativen moment blockiert
werden weil wir den strom produzieren
oft nicht brauchen sondern wir brauchen
den beispielsweise im süden deutschlands
und diese probleme müssen wir lösen
diese probleme kriegen ja auch nicht
wenn du bist in den nächsten jahren wenn
wir jetzt schon sagen wir steigen schon
eher aus der kohleverstromung aus da ist
die zeit ist einfach zu kopf deswegen
haben wir uns ja auch der sinn ausstieg
geeinigt wenn man es dann aber doch
ändern will dann muss man sagen wo der
strom herkommt und deshalb die debatte
auch um die kerne
schulze wirtschaftsminister von
sachsen-anhalt er sich auch um
umweltthemen kümmert
wieder anzutragen uns im studio an
müssen wir tatsächlich auch einen echten
blackout befürchten beispielsweise in
deutschland also kernpunkt das muss man
damit einmal festhalten ist das endlich
diese debatte über das thema kernkraft
und verlängerung der laufzeiten wieder
fahrt aufnimmt denn wir haben ja das
auch gerade eingeblendet gesehen
ungefähr zwölf prozent des dessen was
wir an strom verbrauchen kommt aus der
kernenergie kommt aus den sechs meilern
die es in deutschland hier noch am netz
gibt so wenn man diese rausnehmen und
das ist dann auch ein bisschen die
antwort auf deine frage diese zwölf
prozent dann müssen die natürlich mit
irgendwie anderen energieträgern
aufgefüllt werden ob es dann direkt zum
blackout kommt da würde ich mal sagen
sagen auch fachleute nicht unbedingt man
kann natürlich beispielsweise mit kohle
nach steuern aber wir wissen ja die
kohle trägt massiv zur verschmutzung der
luft bei izmit teil auch verantwortlich
für den klimawandel das bedeutet wenn
wir gerade aus der kohle früher
aussteigen wollen also rund 20% 25% je
nachdem am strommix früher heraus nehmen
wollen dann haben wir zusammen mit der
kernenergie plötzlich eine lücke von
fast 40 prozent dessen was in
deutschland an strom hergestellt wird ja
fast 40 prozent weniger produktion also
wo muss dann dieser strom herkommen der
kann möglicherweise aus sonne wenn sie
scheint und aus wind wenn er wird kommen
aber wenn nicht bedeutet dass
beispielsweise mehr gas oder eben mehr
stromimporte das wird zum einen
beispielsweise atomstrom aus frankreich
dem man ja in deutschland gerade nicht
möchte das wäre also quasi die
perversion dessen was wir hier gerade
machen oder eben zum beispiel kohlestrom
aus osteuropa beispielsweise aus polen
aber auch genau das wollen wir ebenfalls
auch nicht also dann ist schon eine
gewisse crux jetzt drin und da muss man
einfach sich auch ehrlich machen wird
zeit dass man sie ehrlich macht und sagt
wenn es eine energie gibt die auch in
gewisser weise schon beherrschbar ist
mit den risiken die arbeit gleichzeitig
co2 neutral ist mehr oder weniger dann
sollten wir auf diesen energieträger
weiter setzen und das ist die kernkraft
aber wie einfach ist es denn dann zu
entscheiden wir machen doch weiter ich
meine es ist beschlossen wir hatten auch
lange zeit uns darauf vorzubereiten die
energiekonzerne bereiten sich auch
darauf vor
also offiziell sagen die energiekonzerne
in der tat es ist nicht möglich die
laufzeiten noch mal zu verlängern aber
wir wissen wie es gewesen ist unter der
regierung schwarz-gelb angela merkel
guido westerwelle
die hat im herbst 2010 den atomausstieg
den vorher rot-grünen verhängt hatte
oder beschlossen hatte ja nochmal
rückgängig gemacht und dann ein halbes
jahr später nach dem unglück von
fukushima also im märz 2011 dann wieder
ein ausstieg zu beschließen also das
kann man sicherlich hinbekommen wenn man
es möchte